hay un nuevo programa de televisión o
mejor dicho un nuevo reality show
llamado la habitación de la frente azul
la habitación de la frente
azul de hecho es donde debería escribir
con azul pero ahora está con amarillo la
habitación de la frente azul y este
'reality' consiste en lo siguiente
espero que no se aburran siguiendo han
visto al ver las reglas del juego sin
embargo lo voy a decir de una vez del
principio por sería alguien que no ha
visto estas reglas consiste en tener una
habitación como la tenemos aquí y en
esta habitación
tenemos una puerta bueno de hecho eso es
irrelevante pero voy a dibujar aquí la
puerta y bueno en esta habitación
llamada habitación prende azul se van a
sentar en círculos 100 de los mejores
lógicos del mundo voy a ponerlos aquí 1
2 3 mala baba ahí están bien sentados en
círculo viéndose los unos a los otros y
bueno antes de entrar les dicen las dos
reglas siguientes uno al menos una de
las personas que está adentro de la
habitación tiene la frente pintada de
azul al menos uno de ustedes tiene la
frente pintado de azul
bueno esto es importante porque van a
meter a todos con la frente pintada ojos
y no te vean la frente pintada pues
sería muy fácil saber quién es el que
tiene la frente pintada de azul sin
embargo aquí a todos les van a pintar la
frente no forzosamente del color de azul
puede ser que haya uno dos o siempre son
las pintadas con la frente de color azul
sin embargo todos tienen la frente
pintada de cualquier color puede ser el
color que ustedes quieran verde morado o
rojo pero al menos hay uno que tiene la
frente pintada de azul y bueno la
segunda regla que les dicen es la
siguiente tan pronto como tú sepas que
tu frente está pintada de azul entonces
tendrás que abandonar la habitación tan
pronto como tú sepas que eres azul por
lo tanto vas a tener que abandonar la
habitación
y bueno eso es lo que les dicen antes de
entrar a la habitación en la habitación
no hay nadie primero los vendan de los
ojos les pintan la frente de un cierto
color y los van ingresando a todos a la
habitación sin saber si tu frente está
pintada o no del color azul de hecho
para ponerlo más interesante vamos a
apagar la luz y vamos a hacer que todos
vayan ingresando uno a uno todos van
ingresando los vamos a sentar y después
ya que estén las 100 personas adentro en
ese momento les vamos a quitar la venda
de los ojos y vamos a prender la luz y
entonces ellos se van a ver los unos a
los otros pero eso si no puedes ver tu
frente no hay nada que refleje tu imagen
en esa habitación no hay espejos no te
puedes ver en los ojos del otro no hay
forma de que tú sepas de qué color está
tu frente entonces vamos a poner un
ejemplo supongamos que yo soy este tipo
de aquí este tipo que está aquí entonces
en el momento en el que prendan la luz
yo lo único que voy a poder hacer es ver
a todos los demás que están en la
habitación y bueno como ya hemos
mencionado yo no puedo ver mi frente y
luego
si hay alguna persona que tiene la
frente azul si tiene la frente roja la
frente de otro color solamente puedo ver
a los demás ahora bien supongamos que
después de un cierto tiempo cuando yo ya
esté seguro de si tengo o no la frente
azul para apagar otra vez a luz y en ese
momento que apaguen de nuevo la luz las
personas que sepan que tienen la frente
azul va a tener que abandonar la
habitación supongamos que yo soy un
lógico perfecto y ya me di cuenta de que
tengo la frente azul por lo tanto cuando
apaguen de nuevo la luz si yo tengo la
frente azul voy a dejar la habitación y
me voy a salir entonces voy a dejar la
habitación pues es lo que me dicen en mi
segunda regla del juego por lo tanto yo
salman cuando ya me di cuenta que tengo
la frente azul tengo que abandonar la
habitación de tal manera que cuando
vuelvan a prender la luz ya no esté yo
adentro de esa habitación ojo es muy
importante que entiendan que todos somos
lógicos perfectos de hecho nos los dicen
sabemos que todos son unos lógicos
perfectos cada persona que está en la
habitación tiene un conocimiento de
lógica
increíble es más lo podemos poner como
una tercera regla todos en la habitación
son unos lógicos perfectos número tres
todos son unos lógicos perfectos es
decir su conocimiento en lógica es
infalible su poder en lógica es como
ningún otro entonces cada uno sabe que
es un lógico perfecto y bueno antes de
proseguir vamos a darle un repaso a
todas las reglas del juego yo soy un
lógico perfecto me van a sacar de la
habitación me van a vendar los ojos me
van a pintar la frente de algún color de
tal manera que yo no tenga ninguna pista
ni ninguna forma de saber de qué color
está pintada en mi frente me van a meter
a la habitación con mucho cuidado y yo
no voy a saber nada de las frentes de
las demás personas hasta que encienda la
luz cuando encienden la luz yo voy a
tener un tiempo para ver a todos los
demás a todas las demás personas con sus
frentes pintadas y si yo tengo en la
frente pintada de azul en el momento en
el que me dé cuenta de que tengo la
frente pintada de azul
en ese momento tengo que abandonar la
vida
tan pronto como yo me dé cuenta ahora la
pregunta que yo les quiero hacer es qué
pasa si todas las personas que están en
la habitación tienen en la frente
pintada de azul qué va a pasar ahora
supongamos que yo soy esta persona de
aquí salman es el de color café que al
encender la luz yo voy a ver a todas las
demás personas a esta a esta a esta
todas tienen la frente de color azul
díaz verlas a todas en ese momento yo
tengo que deducir si tengo la frente o
no pintada de azul si yo sé que tengo la
frente pintada de azul pues en ese
momento abandonar la habitación y si yo
sé que no tengo la frente pintada de
azul o en su lado acaso todavía todo si
tengo la frente o no pinta de azul me
quedo adentro de la habitación por lo
tanto van a prender las luces y va a ver
personas que ya se hayan ido o puede
existir la posibilidad de que todavía se
encuentren adentro de la habitación
todos los participantes a ver entonces
repitiendo puede existir la posibilidad
de que ya hayan abandonado a algunas
personas o en su lado caso sigan ahí las
99 personas restantes a lo que voy es a
a pasar tarde o temprano mi pregunta es
qué es lo que va a pasar cuando va a
pasar y por qué va a pasar es decir por
qué pasa lo que va a pasar y bueno este
ejercicio yo lo hice alguna vez en un
examen del mighty y lo interesante es
que tiene muchas aplicaciones para la
computación no les puedo dar las
aplicaciones porque les daría una pista
y yo lo que quiero es no darles más
pistas bueno lo que sí puedo intentar
hacer es si no quieren pistas no sigan
adelante el vídeo les voy a dar una
pequeña pista pero si no quieren ninguna
pista no sigan adelante el vídeo la
pista es qué va a pasar si tenemos menos
de 100 personas yo sé que en este
problema tenemos 100 personas pero
intenta ser el caso cuando tienes un
número de personas menor si lo haces con
menos personas será más fácil resolverlo
nos vemos en el vídeo de solución